it's time for drew's news your daily
dance across the good news
rainbow and with me at the desk is my
little pot of gold rusty roswell
hi everybody top of the morning to you
well we're kicking off the top of the
morning with some news
with brews usa today reports that beer
is getting better for you
kind of more and more breweries are
adding electrolytes to their brews
so you're going to start seeing new
beers infused with chia seeds
bee pollen minerals b vitamins and
mediterranean sea salt
and i mean you could rock one of these
after a long hike i mean
what are they not what i this is just
ridiculous
yeah i know they're trying to find an
excuse to drink more beer and i'm not
buying it
i don't like beer because it to me it
tastes like pennies it's not for me
oh yeah i know what you mean but if
someone told me that like a pinot grigio
is something i could grab after the gym
then i you know bench squatted dumbbell
i don't know i don't know about working
out but sounds like a motivator
i actually love beer and i love the
taste of it
so for real i love it i can't even
imagine going to like a ball game or
anything and i even drink non-alcoholic
beer sometimes
it too is like a healthy beer the only
beer that i can have is when i went to a
dodgers game that's all i had was beer
and i
put like ice in it matthew mcconaughey
does the same thing oh my god that's
another thing matthew mcconaughey have
in common
exactly basically the same person all
right listen to this next story
the new york post reports scientists say
that your happiness in your marriage
could be directly connected to your
genes
and i'm not talking levi the university
of arkansas studied the cd38 gene
in 70 couples and found that those with
something called the cc variation
were more likely to feel grateful for
their partner
and to trust them better over long term
and people with other variants
uh they're not doomed they just might
have to work harder at things like
gratitude
trust and forgiveness so do you think
that there's a gene that makes you
better at relationships
i don't have it if there is i don't
i'm like i i but you know and also if
it's genetics you can look at my entire
family history
and they weren't great at relationships
either so
i kind of like i believe this story
i i don't know i i don't buy it so much
really yeah but i also am like not
qualified
at all study some science roster we'll
come back with our own hypothesis
observation
i'll go read a book and get back to you
okay i can tell you this
i am loving our relationship oh god i'm
in this for the long haul
detail i'm really happy no
it's because we're not sleeping together
too oh yeah that helps
yeah well yeah stay tuned for sweeps
i love you that's this is why okay we've
been locked up alone for way too long
is this pigeon hot or not
no i'm serious the new york post reports
that there's a hot pigeon in the city
comedian shelby lorman tweeted a picture
of this foxy fowl
and it's gone viral science writer
rosemary moscow weighed in to say this
bird is actually part pigeon
part dub formerly known as the trinon
bananas
okay i'm for nana's for this and what i
needed to know is
where did she get those pink shoes do
you remember
this reminded me of the the hot duck in
central park like last year that was the
big trend look
that one oh my god yeah everyone was
like following that bird forever
that duck could compete on rupaul's drag
race maybe you'll see it next season